i'm laura ingram and this is a fox news
alert tonight politico is reporting on a
leaked draft of a supreme court opinion
in that mississippi abortion case
and that justice samuel ledo has been
assigned the majority opinion which
according to the draft means roe vs wade
will be overturned now what does this
mean
this returns the abortion issue to the
states which prero is where it always
was so in other words some states will
allow abortion liberally some states
might ban it some will find what they
believe is a middle ground
but i want to say this very clearly
tonight
no matter what you think about this
outcome the leak itself represents a
shocking and unprecedented breach of the
court's confidentiality
which is sacrosanct
and it's key to the court's ability on
any issue
to engage in the give and take and all
the decision making that's required to
reach these decisions based on legal
principles based on the constitution
not
because of political pressure that's
what the legislature does not the court
and those who clerk at the court
especially the law clerks
they are afforded a tremendous privilege
think about it to work at the court to
to learn from the justices
but the inviolable deal that you strike
when you accept that clerkship which is
the most coveted thing you can have as a
young lawyer
is that you swear confidentiality
regarding everything you see and
everything you hear
and especially the internal
deliberations of the court especially
that
it is not up to a law clerk to decide
when the decision of the court will be
announced and it is not up to a law
clerk or any employee of the court
to leak a decision in what is a naked
attempt to try to change the outcome
before the final opinion is issued
now why am i so passionate about this
tonight
i actually know what i'm talking about a
lot of people on television tonight
don't know what they're talking about i
was a supreme court law clerk
and i know because i saw it opinions go
back and forth drafts of opinions go
back and forth
language changes
sometimes sometimes even votes might
change maybe a justice will see an
argument he or she didn't think of it's
rare but it does happen
but this is all done confidentially
to encourage this free exchange of ideas
that's always deemed by everyone doesn't
matter where your political background
is doesn't matter
it's deemed essential to the proper
functioning of our nation's highest
court
now chief justice rehnquist
in our orientation session at the court
said to all of us that there are nine
justices four clerks for each chambers
usually about 36 and then a couple of
the uh retired justices still have
clerks that you know are still at the
court but it's not many not many young
people right it's about
36 40 young people young lawyers
he looked at us and he said
if you leak
anything from this court
you can kiss your legal career bye bye
done
yeah we remember that
and through the entirety of the court's
history no matter how controversial or
disruptive the court's decisions have
been
and i'm talking
decades decades of decisions on freedom
of religion rights of criminals same-sex
marriage
none of those draft opinions ever leaked
you know why
because everyone in that building
understood that was a line that could
never be crossed
and it is a sad commentary that someone
in that building took it upon himself or
herself to totally usurp the role of the
justices and hijack the court's
deliberative process
this was a bold-faced attempt to tip the
balance of the vote one way or another
that
we know which way
the leaker undoubtedly hopes right that
this leaked opinion will drive activists
to the court stores remember they were
desperately banging on the doors during
brett kavanaugh's confirmation hearing
and they think that's going to have an
impact all the activists outside
screaming you know people with all the
colorful signs that's going to have some
impact
that will have one of the justices and
the majority
change his or her vote
but once again
it looks like the left will just smash
an established government process to get
their way
do anything in their power
to stop a principled conservative
majority from issuing a ruling on a
pending case
this leaker
is going to be sorely disappointed and
should be immediately discovered
and disbarred hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else